Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
El físico austriaco Erwin Schrödinger
es uno de los fundadores
de la mecánica cuántica,
pero es más famoso por algo
que en realidad nunca lo hizo:
un experimento mental
que implica un gato.
Se imaginó poner a un gato
en una caja sellada
con un dispositivo que tiene
un 50% de probabilidades
de matar al gato en la siguiente hora.
Al final de esa hora, pregunta:
"¿Cuál es el estado del gato?"
El sentido común sugiere
que el gato está vivo o muerto,
pero Schrödinger señaló
que según la física cuántica,
justo antes de abrir la caja,
el gato está a partes
iguales vivo y muerto,
al mismo tiempo.
Es solo cuando se abre la caja
que vemos un solo estado definido.
Hasta entonces, el gato es
una borrosa definición de probabilidad,
una mitad una cosa
y otra mitad la otra.
Esto parece absurdo,
que era el punto de Schrödinger.
Encontró la física cuántica
tan filosóficamente inquietante,
que abandonó la teoría
que había ayudado a crear
y pasó a escribir de biología.
Por absurdo que pueda parecer,
el gato de Schrödinger es muy real.
De hecho, es esencial.
Si los objetos cuánticos no pudieran
estar en dos estados a la vez,
la computadora que usas
para ver esto no podría existir.
El fenómeno cuántico
de la superposición
es una consecuencia de la naturaleza
dual de partícula y onda de todo.
Para que un objeto tenga
una longitud de onda,
debe extenderse sobre
alguna región del espacio,
es decir que ocupa muchas
posiciones al mismo tiempo.
La longitud de onda de algo limitado
a un pequeño espacio
no puede ser perfectamente definida.
Por tanto, existe en muchas longitudes
de onda diferentes al mismo tiempo.
No vemos las propiedades
ondulatorias de los objetos cotidianos
porque la longitud de onda disminuye
a medida que aumenta el impulso.
Y un gato es relativamente
grande y pesado.
Si tomamos un solo átomo y lo inflamos
hasta el tamaño del Sistema Solar,
la longitud de onda del gato
escapándose del físico
sería tan pequeña como un átomo
dentro de ese sistema solar.
Es Indetectable, así que nunca veremos
el comportamiento de onda de un gato.
Pero algo pequeño, como un electrón,
puede mostrar evidencia
drástica de su naturaleza dual.
Si disparamos electrones, uno a uno,
hacia dos ranuras
estrechas en una barrera,
se detecta el electrón en
el otro extremo en un solo lugar
en un momento específico,
como una partícula.
Pero si se repite esto muchas veces
y se siguen todas las
detecciones individuales,
verás un patrón característico
del comportamiento de las ondas:
un conjunto de rayas,
regiones con muchos electrones
separados por regiones
donde no los hay para nada.
Si bloqueas una de las rendijas,
las rayas desaparecen.
Esto muestra que
el patrón es resultado
de que cada electrón pasó
ambas rendijas al mismo tiempo.
Cada electrón no elije ir a
la izquierda o a la derecha
sino a la izquierda y
la derecha al mismo tiempo.
Esta superposición de estados
también nos lleva a la tecnología moderna.
Un electrón cerca del núcleo de un átomo
existe en un ancho de longitud de onda.
Pon dos átomos muy juntos
y los electrones no tienen
que escoger un solo átomo
sino que se comparten entre ellos.
Así es como se forman
algunos enlaces químicos.
Un electrón en una molécula
no está solo en el átomo
de A o el B, sino en A + B.
Al ir agregando más átomos,
los electrones se propagan más,
compartiendo un gran número
de átomos al mismo tiempo.
Los electrones en un sólido no están
vinculados a un átomo concreto
sino que son compartidos entre todos,
extendiéndose sobre un amplio espacio.
Esta superposición gigantesca de estados
determina las formas como los electrones
se mueven a través del material,
sea un conductor, un aislante
o un semiconductor.
Entender cómo se comparten
los electrones entre los átomos
permite controlar con
precisión las propiedades
de los semiconductores,
como el silicio.
Combinar diferentes
semiconductores correctamente
nos permite hacer transistores
a una muy pequeña escala,
millones en un solo chip de ordenador.
Esos chips y su propagación
de electrones
alimentan el ordenador que estás
utilizando para ver este video.
Una vieja broma cuenta
que el Internet existe
para poder intercambiar vídeos de gatos.
Sin embargo, en un nivel muy profundo,
Internet debe su existencia
a un físico austríaco
y su gato imaginario.